Speaker 1: We told you that Dr. Mehmet Oz, known
for promoting all sorts of quack cures on his
pseudo medical TV show, is running for senator
in Pennsylvania as a Republican candidate. This
is a very important 2022 race, and in fact,
control of the Senate in the next session
could hinge on whether Dr. Mehmet
Speaker 2: Oz wins
Speaker 1: the Pennsylvania Senate
race. Dr. Oz is now very quickly coming
Speaker 2: to I'm the
Speaker 1: victim. They are
canceling me. He says the Philadelphia Inquirer
and others are trying to quote cancel him
by making the editorial decision to
call him Mehmet Oz instead of Dr.
Oz in their publication. That's that's it. And he
says they're trying to cancel me. There's actually
really interesting both grammar and journalism
behind this. There are many media outlets,
Speaker 2: in fact, that have
Speaker 1: decided that when they
talk about Dr. Oz, they will say, Mehmet
Oz, a doctor from Sylvania or, you know,
whatever state they identify him as being from,
not Dr. Oz. Why? Well, the Philadelphia Inquirer
has a style guide to style guide has existed for
a while. Their style guide says Do not use Dr..
On the first reference for anyone with
the title, whether they are a medical
Speaker 2: doctor or have a doctorate
Speaker 1: in a non-medical field to
avoid complaints of unequal
Speaker 2: treatment from
Speaker 1: individuals who worked hard to achieve
doctor and doctorates in non-medical fields. So
the Philly Inquirer rule is we just don't refer to
people, generally speaking as doctor, regardless
of whether they are a medical doctor or not.
Speaker 2: If we did,
then all of a sudden you've got
Speaker 1: anybody with a Ph.D.
in anything you have to say. Doctor every
Speaker 2: single time might be confusing,
Speaker 1: etc. They have two exceptions
exception. Number one is in obituaries.
If someone has died,
Speaker 2: you say Doctor,
Speaker 1: whatever. And if you're
talking about Rev. Dr. Martin Luther King
Jr., that's their exception. Other papers have
rules for not using doctor in popular culture.
But yes, in science as an example.
Speaker 2: So if you're writing an
Speaker 1: article about medicine
Speaker 2: and you quote a
Speaker 1: doctor, you say Doctor,
whatever, if it's popular culture,
Speaker 2: you don't know.
Speaker 1: That's what's at
the core of Dr. Oz is his pop culture
name. He is Mehmet Oz. Television host
who plays a doctor. He is a medical doctor, but in
his role in culture, he has a show in which he is
Speaker 2: a doctor that gives
Speaker 1: advice about different
things. So anyway. Dr. Oz is furious. He says that
this is a cancelation. Let's watch him explain it.
Speaker 3: No, they're not. They're putting their
thumb on the scale. Here's the thing there's
a sudden two gastric response to the campaign.
I'm here in Pittsburgh talking to people,
and it makes me optimistic because they've
got great ideas. Meanwhile, the Inquirer
hates hates that I'm empowering. You hates that
I'm taking on. Some of the established folks hates
that the entrepreneurial solutions that I'm
offering might make sense and they don't like
that. I say what I see. So they want to silence
me, and I tell you it is shocking that it would
make them uncomfortable this early in my campaign,
but I think it's reflective of the movement
we represent. Well, they're trying to cancel
you. I saw your Twitter. That's what you said.
And the Twitter response that I posted back got
a huge response because people see it. I mean,
you can't look away. Why would the Enquirer get
involved in this process? Why would they not want
to call me Dr. Oz? Everyone knows I'm Dr. Oz,
but they don't think it's the right thing to
do if they think it gives me an unfair advantage.
Speaker 1: So that is that really is very
interesting. And, you know, Rand Paul is a doctor,
Senator Rand Paul. He's an ophthalmologist.
He was not referred to as Dr.
Rand Paul during his campaign.
It was Rand Paul ophthalmologist from Kentucky.
OK? Totally reasonable. The difference here
Speaker 2: is that for
Speaker 1: Mehmet Oz, Dr. Oz is actually his his
cultural identity. It's more than his profession.
Speaker 2: And in fact,
Speaker 1: when we say Dr. Oz is running,
we're not saying the guy we know as a
Speaker 2: surgeon, Dr.
Speaker 1: Oz is running. We're saying Dr. Oz,
the figure from the Dr. Oz Show. But the
truth is, it's Mehmet Oz who's a doctor.
It's his personality. It's his celebrity
built around the character, Dr. Oz. That
is why we know who the guy is.
Speaker 2: Who is Mehmet Oz?
A lot of people wouldn't even know.
Speaker 1: If you said to people who is
Mehmet Oz is say, I don't I don't know who's Dr.
Oz? Oh yeah, the guy from TV that makes sense. So
I do believe that Dr. Oz has an argument
to say I'm known as Dr. Oz as a brand,
Speaker 2: not as a professional.
These people don't know me as a doctor
Speaker 1: in terms of my relationship
with them. They know me as the brand,
Dr. Oz from TV. He's probably
Speaker 2: right that it is better
Speaker 1: for him to be written up as
Dr. Oz instead of Mehmet Oz. But also
publications have to make decisions and typically,
particularly when it's not about medicine,
they name candidates by their names.
Speaker 2: Mehmet Oz,
Speaker 1: a doctor from Pennsylvania.
Not Dr. Oz, so completely agree with
the decision. He's not being canceled.
Speaker 2: Their editorial policy is in writing,
and they're following it. You disagree
Speaker 1: with me. Let me know. We'll
also have more on this on our Instagram, which
Speaker 2: you can find at The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 1: Find me on Instagram
at David Pakman as well